thank you
for yourself
it wasn't overnight I think it's worth
saying that um yes ambition is you know
very likely to be in your shopping list
one of the boxes that you tick so to
speak but
Mr
um I'd say feminism has made men less
ambitious in recent years
yeah it's it's
um you know it's put you know if there's
anybody who's who's uh
whose uh has less attention paid to them
it's it's young men and and they're not
encouraged to be ambitious the thing
about ambition is you have to have a
vision of what you can do what's
possible in your life
and they're being ignored so you know it
finding an ambitious man at this precise
moment in history is not an easy thing
to do
you know you have to be I'm not saying
it's your responsibility but what I'm
saying is yeah look for a guy who's got
a potential even if he doesn't know
exactly where he's going
look for a guy who's got potential and
bring help him to bring that out in
himself if you can do that then that's
brilliant I think men need purpose too
and it's hard for them when they don't
have a woman to pursue or show any
interest in them and one out of three
men are either virgins or haven't had
sex in the past year well yeah so I
think there's a large portion of men
that's growing that feels very unseen
yeah and are very lonely and I think and
I think it's like hard to be motivated
if you don't have a woman to work for
absolutely
um ish do you want to show them
so we're gonna watch a video
um this video is by poor man's podcast
shout out
um really great Channel you guys should
look him up if you haven't seen his
stuff already he does really great
compilation and reaction videos
um
the bare minimum but for men y'all we
have to come with a hundred percent we
have to check off every box but as women
we have to be like you know what he
provides he he he's he's loyal so
therefore healing has to be physically
attractive what what boxes are y'all
checking off let me know what you we TR
we check off everything we are smart we
provide we're good wife we're good
Mothers we have good we come from good
homes we can cook we can clean we're
good in bed like everything that we have
to mount up to we do and I feel like as
women
unfortunately we have to settle I'm
going to take it in the order that you
said because when you ask a question off
the top usually people respond with
what's off the top okay right your first
things that you listed had nothing to do
with what men want and women what do
y'all want and that's the problem we
want a feminine woman that wants to be
fit that wants to take care of the small
inconveniences in our lives and
reciprocate the value so if I go the
inconveniences in my life so for me for
example I go to work every single day my
wife gets to sleep in if she wants to I
have a trip to Florida in 10 days she's
already booked the trip she's already
booked the flight she's already taken
care of airbnbs I don't have to worry
about that when I get when I sit down
she brings me a warm plate that's
something that I look for in a woman I
don't care about if a woman can provide
but why would a man care about if a
woman can provide do you feel like your
household is a typical household that we
see now in 2021 or are we now in a in a
atmosphere where it's both women and men
bringing things to the table as far as
providing for a household you say your
your wife your wife gets to sleep in
okay that is that's really good yeah but
that's not typical that's but that's
because my wife selected me based on my
drive and not my appearance she's seen
the vision she's seen where I wanted to
go and she helped me get to that
position she didn't even do that why do
we get called gold diggers do you feel
like your wife with a gold digger
because she looked at your drive she
looked at your ambition she looked at
what you could do for her financially my
wife with me since I was 15. so that in
particular I'm gonna give you that you
know because that's not the typical
situation what I'm trying to get at I
don't if a woman is counted a gold
digger if the man already is solidified
and that's what women want in 2021 and
that's why I don't work out y'all try to
go for men that are already solidified
that look a certain kind of way and then
when it don't work out y'all play dumb
look at it look at Brittany Renner PJ
watch she dealing with PJ Washington oh
he told me this he told me that that
don't matter did he put a ring on that
finger we judge character based off acts
we judge characters we judge character
based on actions they were married
PJ Watson and Brittany Ryan was married
yes oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] that up there but
you looking at like situations like
Sierra and future look at their
situation you dealing with a man that's
been around the block he got kids he
ain't been taking care of his kids and
now you want to lay up with him and this
ain't even something that's celebrity
only reason I use celebrities is because
we all know them people I can go to the
hood right now to show you hella
relationships that's messed up because
it's a dude that's a crackhead he got
three or four baby mamas he ain't doing
nothing with his life but because he
looked a certain way all these women
want to lay up with him and date them
based on potential
but when you're talking about potential
are you talking about Will Smith before
he became Will Smith because that's
potential are you talking about Barack
Obama when Michelle Obama held him down
through law school because that's
potential but are you talking about a
dude that's just sexually attractive
that ain't doing nothing with his life
are you hoping that he get it together
one day while he living off of your uh
your refund check I feel like that's
easier said than done like you said you
want women to go you're telling me women
should date based off potential but as
soon as we do that we get called every
negative name in the book if we look at
a man and say hey he has a good job he
can financially provide for me he might
not be the best looking but I look good
we automatically get labeled a gold
digger but you're telling me that's what
we should be going after but I'm but
you're also saying that look at Brittany
Renner she went she went after a guy
that could financially provide for he
for her he might not have been the best
guy but she would talk would you
consider Brittany a gold digger
uh I would consider an opportunist for
sure and I think that her resume shows
that and I think that that's why she's
catching the flag she's catching the
flag because she promoted herself and
branded herself as a woman that would go
after men for a check why can't we go
based off potential and opportunity you
can go based off a potential and
opportunity but the problem is y'all not
going out for financial an opportunity
y'all going off a man they're already
successful that's the problem there's
nothing wrong with that you have to look
at the age that we're dating at this
point there are people becoming more
successful younger and younger we're not
talking about these people that are
becoming successful in their 50s and 60s
people are coming becoming millionaires
in their young twins that's Instagram
that's the difference in perspective men
don't reach Financial potential the peak
of their financial potential until about
55 to 65 years old that's not always
true though it's not always true but see
now we go into the exceptions but you
don't know who I date what if I date the
except we go into the exception what if
I date the exception but you don't
because if you was dating acceptance you
would still be with them who said that
not with him okay maybe that's fair okay
we're basically getting that is women
are looking for the wrong name me one
good King one good conqueror that had
one woman
LeBron
you think LeBron I got one I'm an
athlete I'm an ex-professional athlete
come on let's keep it up you think
LeBron ain't and I'm not even going and
you can't even count Martin Luther King
because he was sleeping around he was
right so what are we talking about any
good man that has already been
established come on let's just keep it
up
didn't we just discuss that if you text
everybody in your phone right now you
you said 100 success rate would sleep
with you that's not the case for average
man do you know that 30 of men will be
virgins by the age of 30 will have never
touched a woman
that means that women have the selective
choice of who they mate with so you have
the responsibility of who Allah who you
allow in your body y'all choosing them
based off of parents that's what I'm
trying to get at when and y'all got the
whole y'all got the whole y'all got a
layout all you got to do as a woman is
okay so for men our burden to society
our burden to humanity is to build
civilizations that's our job whatever
you want I'm gonna provide men build the
microphone build the camera build the
house this is all men this is what we do
we provide you're gonna make the face
like we don't do that
this is what we do we provide quickly
women have
started things first a lot of the time
but it's okay go ahead the reason why I
feel like it is men because I feel like
men have too many options I feel like
men kind of are at this point like they
find something good
but they're never satisfied
so whenever they feel like something
else come to them that might be a little
bit better Unfortunately they hop on
that and they take that next option so
so when I just said the statistic that
30 of men will be virgins that didn't
like do anything that didn't real thing
that didn't show to you that men don't
by and large have the majority of the
options men get with what men get with
what they can get women get to choose
who they want when it comes to sexual I
feel like virgins could be not [ __ ] too
so no so everybody in your phone that
you get to choose from
oh you can wait till he's done with the
sentence um those are all men that are
in your plethora of people you can be
involved with now it's up for you to
decide whether those men are good
candidates for you to be involved with
now that's your responsibility as a
woman like I said a man's responsibility
is to build civilization in societies a
woman's responsibility is to bring to
bring forth the next generation of
society builders
okay
so I would like to get everyone's
thoughts on that clip yeah go ahead so
much so much came out honestly and
um one thing was that
um you know okay oh I'm sorry you know
obviously I'm talking from the
perspective of somebody who's uh you
know quite a long way from his period